[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر البركه
احييكم وانا راويه القاسم وهذه العربيه
استماع لكنه لم يمسك
معركه الشتاء الاهم الاوكراني يقاتلون في
ظروف ماساويه والروس لم يتعلموا بعد
تسريبات جديده محرجه خامنه اشكك في كفاءه
البسيج وتكليفاته لاغتيال منشقين بالخارج
تعثرت وكشفت
المغرب يبدع و يتاهلوا للدور الثاني
متصدرنا وكرواتيا تطيح ببلجيكا خارج
البطوله
[موسيقى]
خبر مهمه عن الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
يقول انه مستعد للقاء بوتن الشرطه
استعداده لانهاء الحرب نرى ما الذي سيتمخض
عنا مثل هكذا خبر ولكن نبدا بالبيان
المشترك للرئيس الامريكي جو بايدنا نفسه
ولكن مع الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون حرس
البلدين على ضماني عدم تطوير ايران او
حيازه سلاح النووي واشهد بيضا وما يكون في
البيان المشترك بشجاعه المحتاجين في ايران
مؤكدين دعمهم لهم
فرنسا على بناء منظومه دفاعيه اوروبيه
قويه وعلى دعم اوكرانيا في فصل الشتاء
سواء بتعزيز انظمه الدفاع الجوي او توريد
معدات لاصلاح محطات الطاقه
وفي ظهورهما معنا امام الكاميرات اكد
الرئيس الامريكي جو باردن وضيفه الرئيس
الفرنسي
عمق العلاقات بين بلديهما
على مواجهه التحديات مشيرا الى انهما
سيناقشان تعاون في مجال الطاقه اما ماكرون
البحث في كيفيه تجاوزها اضافه الى مناقشه
الملف الغربي للاولويه القصوى حاليا وهو
جاموكرانيا
انيرجي
والفضاء وقد تحدثت على اعاده التوافق
والتنسيق المشترك واعتقد ان هذا مهم جدا
ليكون لدينا تنسيق كبير بيننا لاننا نريد
ان نصلح العواقب المباشره والغير مباشره
للحرب على اقتصاداتنا وعلى شعوبنا وفي نفس
الوقت نريد التحضير للاشيال القادمه
[موسيقى]
كان هذا ما حدث امام الكاميرات اليوم لكن
لينا عد للامس فالعشاء بين الزعيمين يبدو
انه لم يراب صدعا كان قد كتب فصلا في فطور
الصداقه بينهما 40 عاما هذا هو الفرق بين
الثمانيني ومكرون 40 الى ان لهما اخيرا ان
يلتقي معا لوقت اطول يسمح لهما بمناقشه
بعضها متفق عليه والاخر بدل باريس وكانه
يحمل ابتزازا لاوروبا باكملها
في استقبال حاولت امريكا جاهده ان تجعله
نوعيا لكون مكروه اول رئيس يخصه بايضا
بمثل هذه المراسم وبادق تفاصيلها من
الثقافيه والتاريخيه الى اختيار الاماكن
التي يجلسون فيها وصولا الى
مائده الطعام الذي صممت خصيصا لتلك
الزياره كانت اطباقها واستوحات من الوان
علم البدين ومن مكونات معروفه في تقاليد
شعبين مرت مئه عام على علاقتهما
اخفاء التباين الذي باتى ليس ملحوظا فحسب
وانما دفع صحيفه ليموند الفرنسيه الى وصف
مكرونه في هذه الزياره بالمهاجم الشرس بس
اوروبا
للبرلمانيين خلال غدا مع الكونجرس ثم
الاموره باسمائها
بقوانين بايضا لتعزيز الصناعه الامريكيه
معتبره ان اجراءاته ذات النزعه الحمائيه
شديده العدوانيه وقالها بصراحه ربما
تقومون بحل مشكلتكم لكنكم تفاقمون مشكلتي
فانه حينما زار سفاره بلاده في واشنطن غير
بعضا من الكلمات ليصفها هذه المره
بالاجراءات المفتته للغرب
[موسيقى]
مكرونه
كلمه الا والقاها في الارجاء تصدرها الدعم
لاوكرانيا وتداعيات الازمه التي سببتها
تلك الحرب خاصه وان اوروبا تدفع ثمن اكبر
مقارنه بامريكا وان اوروبا تواجه خطر
التخلف عن الركب اذا نجحت الاعانات
المقدمه بموجب القانون الامريكي في جذب
استثمارات جديده
وفرنسا تحديدا ضحيه للتنافس التجاري
الراهن بين واشنطن وبكين اكبر قوتين
اقتصاديتين في العالم
يا اخي
[موسيقى]
وتعبيره
لمواجهه ما وصفه بالدول المارقه والهجمات
الهجينه
سبيس نيسان
اذا مكروه اوصل رسالته في هذه الزياره لكن
ماذا عن بيضن الذي يداري الاختلاف بلاقه
الثمانيه الى تقويه العلاقات مع الشركاء
التقليديين للولايات المتحده وبينهم
الحليف الاقدام وهي الصيغه التي تطلقها
امريكا على فرنسا
مع استراليا وبريطانيا وحينها حرمت فرنسا
من صفقه الغواصات لذا فان بايضا يبذل قصار
جهده لاسترضاء مكروم في هذه الزياره وفق
محللين اضافه الى ان بيض يريد ان يوحد
صفوف البلدين حول موقفهما بشان الصين حيث
ان واشنطن تريد ان يشاطرها الاوروبيون
بشكل اكبر قلقها حياله تصعد قوه بكين في
كل المجلات
في توطيد العلاقات اتخذت امريكا اسلوب
المدح حيث قال الناطق باسم مجلس الامن
القومي في البيت الابيض ان فرنسا تشكل احد
الخيوط التي نسجت بين دولتين كما وعدنا
على الحس القيادي لمكرو وخبرته وحكمته
في الوقت الحالي
وليس على مستوى رئيسي دولتين لاعتقد ان
لقائهما سيحدث فرقا بالاضافه الى ذلك
بالنسبه للنفط فهو محصور بيد منظمه اوبك
ونحن للاسف نعاني من ذلك
مع الاصدقاء الامريكيين وخاصه فيما يتعلق
بالامور الحاليه التي لا يعتقد انها تتعلق
فقط
اعتقد انه من الجيد جدا ان يكون لرئيس
فرنسا علاقات جيده مع رئيس الولايات
المتحده واعتقد ان لدينا رئيسا يتمتع
بمهاره دوليه جيده وسيجد الحلول لتحقيق
التوازن بين الطرفين
العلاقات الدوليه
الكريمين
اذا سمحت لنا استاذ مصطفى الدكتور ادمو
يعني الكثير من الود ولكن الود الظاهر على
الاقل ولكن هل سيشفع لقب الحليف الاقدام
لدى بيدن له فرنسا وبالتالي عمليه مع كل
هذا الود الظاهر ما الذي سيقدمه ايضا
لفرنسا هل هو قادر في زمن اللهم نفسي لكل
دوله همم هل هو قادر على تقديم شيء عملي
فعلا هذا سؤال مهم جدا ومثير لان هذه احدث
قضايا الرئيسيه خاصه هنا اتحدث عن موضوع
التجاري
وقلق الاوروبيين من قانون التضخم مكافحه
التضخم في الولايات المتحده الذي دفع به
الرئيس والذي سيرصد من الاصل 450 مليار
دولار تقريبا سارسل 370 مليار لمساعده
لتشجيع الشركات التي تريد الاستثمار في
بناء السيارات الكهربائيه في بناء
البطاريات المجمده في بناء همم التوربينات
الهوائيه
وهذه طبعا سمحت ليس فقط للشركات الامريكيه
همم للشركات الكنديه والمكسيكيه ومن هنا
ياتي قلق الاوروبيين وهذا كان احد الاسباب
الرئيسيه وراء ربما هذه الزياره
بين البلد الرئيس
ترك الباب قليلا مفتوحا عندما قال ولم يكن
هدفنا الحق الضرر بالحلفاء ولكن وانه من
الممكن التعاون في بعض المجالات في حيث
انه يمكن لبعض الشركات ان تعمل واي شركه
مستعده للعمل فنحن مستعدين ولكن
الاوروبيين والفرنسيين قلقين من ان هذه
الاستثمارات حتى لن تجذب ولم تدعم فقه
الشركات الامريكيه
والكنديه والمكسيكيه الى حد ما قبل ستدعم
همم
لن تدعم بل ستلحق الضرر بالشركات
الاوروبيه مثل مثلا شركه بي ام دبليو شركه
رينو ومن هنا اعتقد ان الباب لا ي- فتح
قليلا ولكنه همم لم تبدوا وكانه تم التوصل
الى تفهم واضح حول هذه القضيه تمام
والرئيس الفرنسي قال بان بان الاوروبيين
ايضا سيدها عن شركاتهم وعن المصالح نعم
مصطفى اودى همم يعني انا اخذ رايك في ما
يخص التباينات الامريكيه ايضا همم
الاوروبيه هناك مخاوف مشتركه من الطرفين
الجانب الاوروبي همم لديه تمن مول
واعتراضات على همم استفاده الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه من الحرب الاوكرانيه
اقتصاديه ومؤخرا من قانون الحد من التضخم
الجانب همم ايضا الامريكي لديه تحفظ وخوف
من التقارب بعض الدول الاوروبيه مع الصين
هل هذه الزياره يمكن ان تحل هذه المشاكل
او هذه التباين بالمواقف
انا عم يجب ان لا نسقط في فخ الابتسامات
الدبلوماسيه والتحيات
الدبلوماسيه المتبادله بين الرئيسين
ماكرون وجديده يجب الاشاره هنا والتركيز
على ان الرئيس ماني المكرون وخلافا لكل
التحركات الدبلوماسيه التي قام بها مؤخرا
استعمل كلمات وخطاب حاد لوصف ما يجري
حاليا بين الولايات المتحده ودول الاتحاد
الاوروبي على المستوى والاقتصادي اليس
بانه استعمل كلمه تفتيت الغرب هذا اتهام
قوي بالنسبه للولايات المتحده وانا اعتقد
بان اذا كانت هذه الزياره قد حملت في
بدايه همم مشوارها عنوان تكريس المصالحه
بعد ازمه الغواصات الاستراليه وبعد النثور
وتشنج التي عرفه محور باريس واشنطن انا
اعتقد بان مالت اليه حاليا هو بوادر طلاق
اوروبي امريكي اذا لم تغير الولايات
المتحده سياستها الاقتصاديه في هذا
الميدان والكل يعني تماما بان مقام به
الرئيس جودا خلال هذه المقاربه لمحاربه
التدخل هو لمحاوله ارضاء رايه العام
الداخلي همم الامريكي عندما يقول امريكا
فيرس ويريد ان يدعم الصناعات الامريكيه
ولكن على حساب حساب المصالح الفضاء
الاوروبي اكثر من ذلك همم يعني ما يخشاه
الفرنسيون الاوروبيون ان هذه السياسه التي
يقوم بها حاليا الرئيس
ستكون بمثابه يعني سياسه استقطاب لكل
الشركات ولكل رؤوس الاموال ولكل الموارد
البشريه الذكيه التي كانت تصنع وتعمل في
الفضاء الاوروبي لكي تنتقل الى الفضاء
الامريكي وتستمر في الفضاء الامريكي على
حساب يعني الفضاء الاوروبي وهنا وهنا انا
نتحدث عن بوادر الطلاق اذا هناك في وقت من
الاوقات التوسل الى الطريق وسط بين ما قام
به او ما يقترح ايضا على الامريكيين وما
يخشاه الاوروبيين من يعني خروج وهروب رؤوس
الاموال والشركات العملاقه الى الفضاء
الامريكي ذلك نحن الان امام علاقات متشنجه
في باطنها لكن في ظاهرها هناك ديبلوماسيه
الابتسامات الديبلوماسيات الحركات
والتحيات الحاره بين الزعيمين دكتور انه
غريب هل همم يمكن لواشنطن ان تتحمل على
الصعيد السياسي والامني وعلى مختلف الصعود
الاخرى في العلاقه التي تجمعها مع اوروبا
ان تيمم اوروبا وجهها شرقا همم كان بتراخ
ما مع روسيا حتى بيظل الحرب الاوكرانيا
كان همم علاقه اقوى اقتصاديه مع الصين
وحتى ربما على مناح اخرى هل همم لحساب
مصالحها الداخليه الخاصه يمكنها ان تتحمل
همم يعني
كم استعمل مكروه هذا اللقب ان يتفتت الغرب
فعلا هذه نقطه مهمه جدا وهي ااا مقلقه كما
ذكرتم وكما ذكر ضيفكم الكريم من باريس
مقلقه
بعين الاعتبار تداعيات هذه الحرب
الاوكرانيه
ونتائجها على الاقتصاديات في اوروبا وعلى
الوضع العام في اوروبا ان اتباعيات التي
يشكو منها الاوروبيون وحتى عندما كان هناك
خلال اللقاء بين الرئيس وعدد من القاده
الاوروبيين في قمه العشرين خرج هؤلاء حسب
القول مسؤول اوروبي كبير قبل يومين لصحيفه
بانه بدا وكان الرئيس
او غير همم لم ياخذ عن الاعتبار التجاريات
التي تتركها السياسات الامريكيه وخاصه
القانون مكافحه التضخم وقانون
وضع القيود على شراء شيب او الرقائق من
الصين والسماح للصين ب همم شراء ايضا في
رقائق ومواعب معدات يمكن استخدامها في هذه
الرقائق ولذلك هذه مخلقه ومزعجه جدا
للاوربيين والاوروبيين يعتقدوا ان هم
واشنطن تستغل هذه الامور لحمايه لوضعها
ولتعزيز اقتصادها على حساب اوروبا ومن هنا
تاتي اهميه هذه همم التحركات وهنا ايضا
اتفقنا ما ذكره الاستاذ مصطفى فيما يتعلق
مثلا بموضوع ان هذه الدبلوماسيه لهجه لغه
دبلوماسيه وفيما يتعلق باوكرانيا كانت
هناك ايضا كان هناك التركيز على انه يجب
ان يكون هناك تعاون ولكن نقطه مهمه اعتقد
يجب الاشاره اليها الرئيس ماذا على الرغم
من الموقف الذي المتشدد الذي يتبناه انه
لن يلتقي
بالرئيس الروسي همم وقال بان همم انه
مستعد للقاء به اذا كان مستعدا صحيح فيها
نوع من اللغه المختلفه اما كنا نسمعه
القرن صحيح
يعني
يتهم القاده الاوروبيون او الاوروبيين سيد
مصطفى بانهم اتباع للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هي تقرر وهم ينفذون هل زياره
مكروه وما تحدث به بغداء العمل امام
الكونجرس وانتقاده لكل همم القوانين
الاقتصاديه الامريكيه هو بمكان يقول نحن
خلفائكم نعم ولكن يجب ان تراعوا مصالحنا
الاقتصاديه وايضا السياسيه بالمقابل ما
توقعك لرده الفعل الامريكيه هل سيكون هناك
تفاعل ويعني مراعاه ومراجعه للقوانين التي
تراعي المصالح الاوروبيه
نعم يعني الموقف الفرنسي او المبادره
الفرنسيه حاليا في واشنطن وهي الهدفها
الاساسي وهو ان تحمل تحذيرا الى الاداره
الامريكيه باسم دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
وباسم مصالحها دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
مفادها هذا التحذير وهذه الرساله ما فاتها
ان دائما كلنا تحت قبه الاطلسي كنا حلفاء
وتحتها ايضا قبه العالم الغربي الاقتصادي
الليبرالي العائله الغربيه كنا حلفاء لكن
ما يجري حاليا وهو انكم انتم لا تفكرون
الا في مصالحكم القوميه الا في امريكا
فورست هل هذا يعني ان ان لازلنا حلفاء في
هذه المعركه الاقتصاديه والسياسيه
والعسكريه العالميه ام الكل سياخذ طريقه
قبل ان يتوجه الرئيس من الماكرون الى
واشنطن كان هناك حديث عن نوعيه الاجوبه
التي يمكن ان يقدمها الاوروبيون
لمواجهه هذا الوضع الجديد وهنا كما نقترح
انه يجب على اوروبا ان تفكر في نفسها وان
تبلور لا يمكن ان نسميه بال باي اوروبيا
اكت يعني ان الكل يريد ان يصنع اوروبي وان
يشتري اوروبي وان يستهلك اوروبي دون
اللجوء الى ما هو الصيني او امريكي هل هذا
ممكن في اللحظه الحاليه هناك عده صعوبات
خصوصا واننا عندما ننظر الى المانيا مثلا
المانيا على مستوى الاتحاد الاوروبي عندما
قررت ان تفتح عمليه تسلحها لم تختار
الاصطلاح الاوروبي الذي كان مجهز هي
اختارت السلاح الامريكي باسمي التحالف
الوثيق بين المانيا ودول الاتحاد الاوروبي
لذلك هذه هي الصعوبه التي يواجهها حاليا
ايمانويل ماكرون هو يحاول ان يقنع الاداره
الامريكيه بالعمل على تحالف وثيق بينه
وبين دول الاتحاد الاوروبي لكن داخل
العائله الاوروبيه هناك من لا يريد ان
يمشي في نفس الخطه يريد ان تكون لا هو
علاقات تفضيليه مع الاداره الامريكيه وهذا
هو التحدي الكبير الذي يواجه حاليا شكرا
جزيلا لكما اذا من واشنطن ومن باريس
الدكتور ادمون غريب والكاتب والمحل
السياسي مصطفى
[موسيقى]
وفي العربيه 360 ايضا صرخه جديده من
البرلمان العراقي الامن المائي للبلاد في
خطر وتركيا وايران لم تلتزم بالاتفاقيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اكد الرئيس الفرنسيه
خلال الايام المقبله مع نظيره الروسي
فلاديمي
الامريكيه ان الحرب في اوكرانيا معقده
وتتطلب العمل للوصول الى سلام عادل و
مستدامه لا يفرض على
الاوكرانيين او يرفض هو احد الطرفين ولا
يفرض عليهم على المدى المتوسط او البعيد
من الممكن العوده الى المفاوضات
لكن المفاوضات التي تحدث عنها مكروسه
تنتظر حتم المعركه الشتاء او على الاقل
معركه مدينه بخموت التي تتركز عليها
الانظار الان هذه المدينه التي اصبحت نقطه
ربما تكون الاسخن في الحرب القتال للسيطره
على بخمود قد يشهد اكثر المعارك شراسه حتى
الان في اوكرانيا في اختبار لما يمكن ان
تكون عليه حرب الشتاء المرتقبه صور الخطوط
الاماميه المنشوره من بخموط اظهرت ان
المدينه التي كانت تضم سبعين الف سنه قد
اضحت انقادا وتحت وابل مستمر من نيران
المدفعيته روسيه
[موسيقى]
لكن ما هي هذه المدينه وما اهميه لماذا
القتال المحتدم عليها
على طريق رئيسي يؤدي الى مدينه
ضمن تقدم باص الصناعيه التي لم تسيطر
عليها روسيا بالكامل بعد هي ايضا
لامدادات الجيش الاوكراني في المنطقه
وشهدت معارك عنيفه في عام 2014
و2015 عندما استولت القوات الانفصاليه
المواليه لروسيا لفتره وجيزه بالنسبه
لروسيا الاستيلاء على بخموط سيؤدي لقطع
خطوط الامداد الاوكرانيه اضافه لفتح
الطريق للقوات الروسيه للتقدم نحو
كروماتوسوفيانوس المعقيلين الرئيسيين
لاوكرانيا في مقاطعه
اكثر من خمسه اشهر قصفت القوات الروسيه
بخموت كما تسارعت وتيره الهجوم البري
بقياده مجموعه فاجنر الامنيه التي تضم
جنود سابقين روسيا تحتاج الى نصر في بخموت
لانها تفقد السيطره على مساحات واسعه من
شمال شرق اقليم خاركه بسبب هجوم مضاد
اوكراني الشهر الماضي اضافه لسيطره القوات
الاوكرانيه على خيرسو بين كار وفر تتراوح
العمليات العسكريه حول بخموت المدينه التي
هاجرها 90% من سكانها بسبب المعارك بسبب
او بحسب حاكم الاقليم
[موسيقى]
اذا القوات الروسيه حول محمود بدات بتحقيق
بعض المكاسب في الاسابيع الاخيره بعد اشهر
من الهجمات المستمره على خط المواجهه
الاوكراني مع تواصل ارسال التعزيزات في
محاوله للسيطره على المدينه لكن وسط غياب
انباء دقيقه عن سير المعارك يكهن بعد
المراقبين بان الروسي يبالغون في الحديث
عن تقدمهم بسبب الرغبه في استعاده بعض
الهدوء داخليا وسط تقارير عن تلاش الروح
المعنويه بين جنود الخطوط الاماميه ومع
اقتراب فصل الشتاء نشر الجيش الاوكراني
لقطات اظهرت جنود في فنادقهم التي يتحسنون
فيها كما نشاهد
ووصفه الظروف التي يعيشونها
وصفها المحللون بالبائسه مسؤول كبير في
الباندا وصف الوضع حول بخموت بانه يبدو
مشابهه جدا للاوضاع في الحرب العالميه
الاولى
[موسيقى]
لكن هل من الممكن ان تغير روسيا من
استراتيجتها للسيطره على بخمود خاصه وان
القتال في هذه المدينه متواصل منذ اشهر
من سته اشهر دون تحقيقه تقدم من يذكر مع
دراسه الحرب الامريكي قال ان الجهود
العسكريه الروسيه حول محمود
في التعلم من الحملات المقرفه السابقه
التي ركزت على اهداف غير مهمه من الناحيه
الاستراتيجيه اضاف المعهد ان معركه مميته
لك الى الجانبين فمن الجانب الروسي يمكن
لهم استنزاف قواتهم وربما السيطره على
المدينه لكن على ارض الواقع لن يكون
المقابل ذا جدو معهد دراسه الحرب قال انه
حتى اذا دخلت قوه الروسيه محمود ايضا دخلت
الى داخلها او فرضت انسحابا اوكرانيا من
المدينه الا انها لن تعوض عن التكاليف
المرتبطه
اشهر القتال الطاحن القائم على الاستنزاف
روسيا الان تسيطر على العديد من المناطق
المحيطه بمخنوث الا ان الهجمات الروسيه
حول المدينه فضلا عن انها تستهلك نسبه من
القوه القتاليه الروسيه تسهل استمرار
الهجمات المضاده الاوكرانيه في اماكن اخرى
الخسائر الروسيه في اوكرانيا بشكل عام منذ
بدايه الحرب وصلت الى قرابه 88,000 قتيل
بحسب هيئه الاركان العامه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه في تقديرات صدرت امس مجله نيوز
ويك في الامريكيه التقت بخبراء عسكريين
قال احدهم انه بعد اكثر من تسعه اشهر من
الحرب ستسعى روسيا لمواصله العمليات
وتحقيق اهدافها المعلنه المتمثله في نزع
سلاح اوكرانيا
منها بحسب موسكو خبيرون اخر قال ان
التحصينات الحدوديه الروسيه بالقرب من
منطقه خارج كيف وهي من المناطق التي تشن
فيها اوكرانيا هجوما مضادا تعكس ان روسيا
يج ان تتخذ موقفا دفاعيا وليس هجوميا في
الحرب لكن على الرغم من كل التقارير
الغربيه قالت متحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا زخرفا الاسبوع الماضي ان
روسيا ليس لديها بديل سوى تحقيق اهدافها
في اوكرانيا مجمل الاوضاع على الارض في
مخموت يرصده لنا حذيفه عادل
قد تصبح معركه باخمت اعنف معركه في الحرب
باكملها حيث يستوي الرؤوس للسيطره عليها
منذ اشهر يعني معهد دراسات الحرب
الاوكراني يرى ان بعض هي فخ لروسيا حيث
استنزفت فيها قوه جيشها بشكل كبير وتكبدت
في سبيلها خسائر فادحه تفوق اي فائده
عملياتيه من الاستيلاء عليها اما بخصوص
الوضع العمليات الراهن فقد قصف الروس
منطقه الفاسكي وفيلا داره كما اجرت القوات
الجويه الروسيه عمليات استطلاع جوي متفرقه
فوق الجزء القديم من افديه افكار
هجوما صاروخيا على موقع للبنيه التحتيه في
كرخوبا اما تضرر الاكبر فكان في اتجاه
هيهر نتيجه القصف في المكثف
وينضم الينا من موسكو العقيد المتقاعد من
الجيش الروسي والمحلل العسكري اهلا بك
معنا
يعني سؤالنا قبل قليل وحاولنا ان نستعرض
بعض السيناريوهات لو سمحت ان تؤكد لنا
بعضها وتنفي لبعض الاخر ربما حول
السيناريوهات اذا كانت روسيا مضطره الى ان
مضطر الى ان تغير استراتيجيتها
يجب الاشاره الى ان الضحيه الاولى
لايه حرب مهما كانت هي الحقيقه عندما نسمع
الى تصريحات كيف ما يخص بالانتصارات
القادمه
[موسيقى]
روسيا كدوله
خسائر همم
90,000 قاتل جندي روسي في
جلسه اشهر وهمم
انا هتقول مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني انه في
خلال
نصف السنه سوف يقدم تصريحات من شبه جزيره
القرم هذا كله قد يؤدي الضحك له لا كان
هذا الموضوع مرتبط بالدماء
[موسيقى]
على سؤالي تحديدا هل باعتقادك روسيا مضطره
الى ان تغير استراتيجتها العسكريه في
بخموط لم يعد بالامكان خساره المزيد من
المعارك بالنسبه الى روسيا يعتقد البعض
هي مدينه تاريخيه روسيه اسمها تومسك تم
تغيير اسمها
[موسيقى]
والان هناك تقدم ولو بطيء للجيش الروسي في
منطقه همم ارطغرل
والاحد يكون حتى في رئاسه اركان الجيش عن
الهجوم الحاسب في منطقه الخروج او الى
اخره همم
التقدم للجيش الروسي هو خير دليل على ان
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه في هذه العمليه
العسكريه هو هي امر ثابت ومستمر ويتيم
انجاز المهام الواقع على مهام على ملاعب
الكره
[موسيقى]
ليس نتيجه الدرب القوي للجيش ولكن
بالامر الصادر من قياده الجيش يعني كان
هناك
انا معكم انه الجيش الروسي انسحب من غير
صوت دون معركه دون اي همم
طلقه واحده وهذا كان قرار سياسي
اوكرانيا بقنابل دقيقه من انتاج بوينغ مع
نظام جي بي اس يصل مداها الى 150 كيلو متر
يعني همم يعني ضعف هيمارس التي حققت
النتائج كبيره للاوكرانيين اللي هي من
تقديم الدول الغربيه كيف يمكن ان تقلب
المعادله اكثر واكثر لصالح الاوكرانيين
يعني يتخوف الجيش الروسي من هذه المعدات
المتطوره جدا التي بدات تتلقاها اوكرانيا
الا تحسبون لها
الجيش الروسي لا يتخوف ولا اداره الروسيه
تخاف
مع
الاتخاب بعيد القرار انه فعلا
الخارق تعمل بكل ما في وسعه لتزويد الجيش
الاوكراني
بمختلف انواع الاسلحه ولكن يجب الاشاره
الى ان حتى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تمتنع عن تزويد الجيش الاوكراني باحدث
انواع الاسلحه على سبيل المثال همم حتى
همم طائره مقاتل اف 16 وهي همم في همم
يعني هي الطائره التي تستخدمها مختلف جيوش
العالم حتى الجيوش العربيه مختلفه
ابداعات
عن تزويد الجيش اللبناني تحسبا لي
[موسيقى]
التوجه
المباشر
للجيش الروسي فيعني هناك تحسبات وهناك
منورات
علما بان في نهايه الامر هذا هي الحرب
ليست بين روسيا اوكرانيا ولكن هذا هو
الاشتباك بين روسيا والغرب
شكرا جزيلا لك العقيد المتقاعد من الجيش
الروسي والمحلل العسكري سرقه شاشكوف من
موسكو تحيتنا اليك
[موسيقى]
قيل في قانون الحفاظ على العلاقات راويه
انما يحدث في الداخل لا يجب ان يذاع للعلم
لكن هذا ما لم يستطع نظام الايراني الحفاظ
عليه نتحدث عن اروقه البيت الواحد الذي
اخترقته وكاله ايران انترناشونال وكشفت
المستور حول نشر سريه اعدتها وكاله انباء
فارس الايرانيه الرسميه للقائد العام
الايراني للحرس الثوري الايراني حسين
سلامي بعد ان وقعت بايدي مجموعه هاكرز
تدعى بلاك ريورد
123 صفحه تحدثت بالحقيقه بعيدا عن ما
تبديه تصريحات الرسميه للنظام الايراني
عنوانها ان الاحتجاجات لن تنتهي قريبا ولن
تتوقف اقوال هذه النشره السريه ماخوذه عن
لسان المرشد علي خمنائي الذي افصح لسلامه
عن مخاوفه بشان التظاهرات فقد راى المرشد
ان النظام بات متاخرا عن الركب في الحرب
الاع للتعتيني عما يجري وايهام المدنيين
بانها مؤامره غربيه تصريح حمل اعترافا
ضمينيا بان النظام يواجه ثوره حقيقيه
ويعاني شيخوخه مترهله من قمه سلطاته وصولا
الى القاعده وليس انتهاء بقوه النسيج التي
وصفها خامنئي بغير الفعاله وبالعاجز عن
التعبئه لوقف الاحتجاجات الشعبيه لم تتوقف
الاقرارات هنا فحسب بل ان الارقام ايضا
تعرضت للتلاعب واظهار محدوديه الاحتجاجات
فبينما تضج الشوارع بست 100,000 من
المتظاهرين تحول الرقم الى مجرد 40,000 في
التصريحات القضائيه وكشفت الوثيقه ايضا ان
70% من الايرانيين لا يرغبون اطلاقا في
الخروج في تظاهرات داعمه للنظام وان الروس
زود السلطات الايرانيه بنتائج التنصت
الاقليميه لاجهزه المخابرات ذهبيه على
ايران
[موسيقى]
ومن مهد التظاهرات سقف مسقط راس الشابه
مهسا اميني لا يكل ولا يمل الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي من العباره الاكثر
ترديدا خلال فتره الاحتجاجات قائلا انها
مدبره من الاعداء وان الغرب خاصه امريكا
التي تشن تيارا معاديا ضدنا هي التي تتولى
ذلك مضيفا ان ان البلاد هو الخط الاحمر
والقضيه المحوريه لكل مجتمع ودوله ولن
يسمح لاحد بان يمس ايران مشددا ايضا على
انها هنا مع مرتكبي الجرائم اضافه الى
ضروره تقديمهم للعداله حاول هذه المره ان
يشهد عاطفه المدنيين من محافظه كردستان
مطربه البلاد مع تاكيدها ان العدو لا يعني
من يواجه بل انه يجهل ان كردستان ضحت
بدمائي سكانها مستذكرا انه انتصروا في
حروبهم في الماضي ويقصد الحرب الايرانيه
العراقيه قبل نحو نصف قرن في مقال مطول
لصحيفه واشنطن بوست ساند الى شهاده خمسه
15 مسؤولا في واشنطن واوروبا وشرق الاوسط
اكدوا ان النظام يصعد من جهوده لملاحقه
لمعارضين في الخارج كما في الداخل حيث
اوضح المسؤولون ان اجهزه المخابرات والامن
الايرانيه تعتمد الى حد كبير على الوكلاء
لتنفيذ خططهم وتقدم مئات الالاف من
الدولارات للصوص للمجوهرات وتجار المخدرات
وغيرهم من المجرمين لتنفيذ مخططات القتل
وملاحقه المعارضين
ووفقا الصحيفه افشت بل افشلت عده وكالات
امنيه حول العالم محاولات اغتيال قام بها
ايرانيون مثلا كمحاولات قتل المستشار
الامن القومي السابق في امريكا جون بولتن
في واشنطن وواحده وواحده الاختطاف الصحفيه
الايرانيه الامريكيه مسيحه لنجاد في مدينه
نيويورك عدا عن محاولات بالفشل لقتل
مواطنين بريطانيين اضافه الى احباط عمليه
باستخدام تاجر مخدرات ايراني لقتل الصحفي
الفرنسي
في العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس
[موسيقى]
وفي العربيه 360 ايضا
الجمهور الامريكيه اوصل رساله للامير
ويليام وقرينته كيت رساله بدات محرجه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الازمات لا تاتي فرادا
على العراق وشعبه سياسيا اقتصاديا
واجتماعيا اخر الازمات الجفاف نهر ديالى
الواقع شرق بغداد اصبحت مياه بحله في مشهد
يصلي الضوء على ازمه الجفاف غير المسبوقه
التي تعانيها مناطق في العراق
جفاف يعتبر الاسوا منذ اكثر من تسعه عقود
مع تراجع هطول الامطار والانحار مياه
الانهار بحسب الامم المتحده يعدل العراق
من بين خمس دول تعتبر اكثر تاثرا بتغير
المناخي ايضا مع مواجهه ارتفاع كبير في
درجات الحراره الجفاف يضرب محافظه دياله
التي اعتادت سابقا على وفره كبيره خلال
المواسم الزراعيه وهو ما تغير خلال هذا
العام وسائل الاعلام عراقيه نقلت عن
مسؤولين في المحافظه قولهم ان المحافظه
بحاجه لدعم مالي من الحكومه للق على ازمه
الجفاف وشح المياه دعينا الحكومه الى
اسعافها لمواجهه الازمه الخنقه التي تكررت
تحذيرات المسؤولين منها على مدار الاشهر
الماضيه
[موسيقى]
المره الرابعه يعني الموسم الرابع 4 سنوات
جدا
وخزاناتنا مما اجبرنا على تحديد
المساحات المزروعه من الموجب شتوي
نهر دلا هو اهم روافد نهر دجله لكنه ليس
الوحيد في هذه الازمه فمن ذو نحو 20 عاما
يعاني العراق شحا واضحا في المياه لدرجه
ان بعض مناطق نهر دجله يمكن عبورها مشيا
على الاقدام في المناطق التي ضربها الجفاف
في العراق تقلصت المساحات الزراعيه باهم
المحاصيل الاستراتيجيه في مقدمتها القمح
والارز بالاضافه الى المحاصيل العقليه
والخضراوات ولتعويد المساحات الزراعيه
المفقوده يتجه المزارعون لاستخدام المياه
الجوفيه للزراعه في محاوله لتخطي الاسباب
لكن ما زاد من ازمه الجفاف تغيير مسارات
الانهار القادمه من ايران اضافه لانشاء
سدود وانفاق مائيه ما دفع احد ملاك قطعان
المواشي الاتهام ايران بزياده الازمه
السوءه
النيران ساد طيران
تتزحم ولوحات المشاريع الاغاثيه للنازحين
في احد اكبر تجمعاتهم بمارب والمعاناه
مستمره في مخيم السويداء غربي المحافظه لا
يختلف الحال كثيرا عن بقيه تجمعات النزول
فما اشتداد موجه البردي تزداد المخاوف من
تسجيل حالات وفيات جديده من الاطفال وكبار
السن في خيام مهترئه مزقتها الرياح
الناجحون يعانون كثيرا من شده البرد
النازحون ما في لاعيدان وترابيل يصلحونها
نريد نريد حلول جذريه النازحين في هذا
المخيم يوجدوا لنا همم مخيمات حلوه جدا
كراتير حلول جذريه بحيث نازح همم يحصل
ماوى ضمه ويضم اولاده
تحاول النسوه بعد ان فقدنا ازواجهن في
الحرب جمعه اغصان الاشجار ثم تغطيتها
بالترابيل والاقمشه في محاوله لتوفير مسكن
امن لابنائهن يقيهم موجه البرد القارس
فيما ام ياسر التي حصلت على احدى الخيام
تجهز بيديها ماده الاسمنت لتسد الفجوات
التي تتسلل منها الرياح البارده وهكذا
الحال من التجهيزات البسيطه للنازحين في
ظل غياب المسكن الملائم لطبيعه المنطقه
وظروف النزوح
ها معرش له جهال هكذا واحد جنب واحد جنب
واحد علشان ندخل وسطه كل يوم نسوي بطانيه
وتكمل بطانيه وتقطع من الشمس من الرياح
ونرجع ثاني وعلى هذا طرد عسل
شبكه
ونشتري نسدد على نفوسنا هكذا من البرد
الواحد
والانتقالي عرضتها المنظمات الاغاثيه
واقرتها كتله الماوى وواحده النازحين في
مارب العام الماضي لكانها لم تصل للنازحين
الى اليوم
الشتاء وقاسم على النازحين في مارب لذا
يحاولون تامين مساكنه تقيهم واطفالهم موجه
البرد القادمه من اعواد الاشجار محمود
الحميدي لقناه العربيه مارب
في تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 المجاعه
التي طالت ملايين الاشخاص في اوكرانيا في
ثلاثينيات القرن الماضي في عهد ستالين هي
اباده جماعيه تصريح او الاقرار بالاحرى هو
للبرلمان الالماني وهو بحسب احد النواب
تحذير لروسيا مع احتمال التكرار
الماسترتها
الان هو وضعها الميداني على الارض
وفي فيديو اليوم اعد الامير ويليام وزوجته
كيف العده لزيارتهم الاولى منذ 8 سنوات
للولايات المتحده حضر امير واميره فوز
مباراه في كره السله ومجرد ظهور صورته مع
على الشاشه
هتفحشت من الحضور باسم الولايات المتحده
عاده مرات
فيه حادث عنصريه جديده في قصر كانت بطلتها
مساعده سابقه للملكه الراحله
اليزابيثات او ربما كان لصالح الثنائي
الملك الاخر هاري
الولايات المتحده وتخليا عن مناصبهم
الملكيه بعد خلاف حول النقطه ذاتها
القصر الملكي
ونختم مع صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 من
اليابان
ان ذاكرته ضعيفه سينسى ربما انه احتفل او
اكيد سينسى انه احتفل وسيطلب المسد
في متابعه ملفات العربيات المشاهدين
المزيد من الاخبار والتحليلات على
العربيات
واخبار الساعه صحه طاهر
ههه صهيب مساء الخير
يعني وهذه ميزه الثنائي ههه هذه الثنائيه
الله يبارك فيك طبعا فعلها اسود الاطلس
يعني المنتخب العربي يفعلها طبعا هارد لك
تونس والسعوديه المغربي لن يصعد الى دور
السته عشر لاول مره من 36 سنه الف الف
مبروك
[موسيقى]